hello if you weren't living under a rock
these past months then you surely have
heard about diffusion models we mean
openly eyes diffusion models beat gans
at image synthesis
openai's model glide generates more
photorealistic images than dali with
text guided diffusion models what are
these diffusion models and why do they
keep impressing us with their image
generation capabilities
this is what we will explain in this ai
coffee break
here's my alert that we should thank
weights and biases for supporting us for
this video today we would like to
highlight the weights and biases feature
called alerts which comes in very handy
when you're keeping track of your
machine learning experiments you can be
notified by slack or email if your
weights and biases run has crashed or
whether a custom trigger has been
reached such as your loss going to not a
number or a step in your machine
learning pipeline has completed waste
and biases alerts apply to all projects
where your launch runs including both
personal and team projects get started
with weights and biases alerts in two
quick steps turn on alerts in your
weights and biases user settings you can
get notified via slack and or via email
for whether your run is finished whether
it has crashed or any other custom
trigger you like for custom triggers add
1db dot alert to your code wherever
you'd like to be alerted for a custom
trigger
i think that the alert feature is
extremely useful even in my low cost
projects but imagine that some weights
and biases users have saved large cloud
gpu bills by being alerted early to
crash trends while training large
expensive models now back to the fusion
models
let's say we want to generate an image
what generative models are there on the
menu in 2022 well we can identify four
main types of generative models
here i am using the visualization from
the awesome blog post of lillian wang do
check it out especially if you're all
into the cool mass the blog post about
diffusion models is linked in the
description below so we have four types
of generative models on the menu let's
see what the principles of each model
paradigm are
first we have generative adversarial
networks or short gans they generate
images from noise much like a diffusion
model but this is where the
commonalities stop so we have this
generator neural network starting from
noise or from some informative
conditioning variable like a class label
or a text encoding and it generates
something that should look like a
realistic image the success of the
generator is rated by the discriminator
who labels the image as being either a
true image coming from the training set
or a fake one synthesized by the
generator if you're curious about how
gans work in more detail check out our
previous video about this then there are
variational autoencoders
vanilla autoencoders take the input
encoded by usually reducing it to a
latent space of lower dimensionality the
decoder part tries to reconstruct the
input again with the goal to minimize
the distance between the input and its
reproduction
so far vanilla autoencoders structure
this latent space z however they see fit
as long as they are able to reconstruct
the data seen during training but this
is not necessarily a meaningful
structure meaningful could mean that
similar data points are close to each
other and these similar points are far
away variational autoencoders have their
own way of introducing a meaningful
structure they have an extra
regularization term on this latent space
to make sure that the latent
representations here are not ordered
anyhow but according to a predefined
distribution usually gaussian this makes
the space around the learned data points
behave better and one can better sample
from points in between training data
points with this regularization we is
implicitly learn the data distribution
a class of models that explicitly learn
the data distribution are flow-based
models in a nutshell flow-based models
do not learn just any encoder and
decoder but specific ones they apply a
transformation f parameterized by a
neural network onto the data much like
the encoding step in autoencoders but
then the decoder is not a fresh neural
network that has to learn the decoding
process by itself but simply the exact
inverse of the function f to achieve
this invertibility of f with neural
networks requires quite some tricks we
will not discuss in this video we'll
link lillian weng's blog post about this
in the video description and finally on
the generative menu we get to the model
class we are talking about today
diffusion models how do they work we
cite from the figure here diffusion
models gradually add gaussian noise and
then reverse well everything is crystal
clear okay bye
now miss coffee bean let's break it down
a bit let's talk about the term
diffusion models first why are these
models called like this
diffusion is a term you have maybe heard
in physics classes about thermodynamics
if we have a system with a high
concentration of a substance like
perfume in a certain place then it is
not in equilibrium to transition to
equilibrium the diffusion process
happens the perfume molecules move from
the place of higher concentration to
everywhere in the system such that the
concentration becomes the same
everywhere diffusion makes everything
homogeneous in the end
so this is what the blog post here means
by withsight diffusion models are
inspired by non-equilibrium
thermodynamics and they define a markov
chain of diffusion steps a mark of what
a markov chain it's a sequence of
variables in which the state of one
variable depends only on the previous
event so this is markov and this is not
so markov anymore now it's markov again
so for our diffusion models we have this
markov chain where random noise is added
to the data we take the image and during
the forward diffusion process we add a
certain amount of noise to it
sequentially it's markov we store the
noise here image and we go on to
generate the new image in the sequence
by adding a little bit more noise and we
do this a certain number of steps if we
do this infinitely many times we get to
an image that is just noise but infinity
is something that only mathematics can
deal with right in reality we do this
only let's say 150 times to get a last
image in the sequence that is a good
approximation of just noise and here is
where it becomes interesting how can we
generate images with this thing we take
a neural network and learn the reverse
diffusion process so the backward
diffusion process involves the same
network the same weights being applied
at each step to generate the image from
t to t minus one to simplify the problem
even further one could choose to predict
not the image but the noise at each step
which needs to be subtracted from the
image instead of letting the network
predict the image in any case the choice
of the architecture of the neural
network must be such that it preserves
the data dimensionality like a unit a
unit is a convolution-based neural
network that is downsampling an image
into a lower dimensional representation
and reconstructs it during upsampling
the downsampling and upsampling stacks
communicates through skip connections
and the unit used in these two papers
also uses global attention in the lower
resolution layers because you know it's
all you need after all but why would we
ever want to use such a diffusion model
when there are gans around and there's
gpt like models such as dali
the short answer is dali is great
concerning generation diversity what you
see here are now generations of dali
which was the previous model from open
ai being able to generate images from
text but while the cartoon-like images
are great and diverse the photorealism
of this cat or these signs is not
exceptional but ali was not a diffusion
model it was basically a gpt like model
auto regressively generating the image
with a piece of text and the start of an
image as an input if we do want the
model to go bananas and generate many
versions of a baby daikon radish in a
tutu walking a dog
or the avocado armchair dali is great
but if we care more about high fidelity
and realism in our generations we
usually turn to gans capable of
producing photorealistic images only
that diffusion models are even better at
realism as we have seen in this paper
also from openai because you see
diffusion models are more faithful to
the data in a sense while again gets
random noise or a class conditioning
variable is input and bam it must
produce a realistic sample diffusion
models are much slower iterative and
guided process when reverting from noise
to the real image by going through
iterations and iterations of denoising
there is little room for going very far
straight the generation process runs
through all of these checkpoints and
that each step more and more details can
be added into the image
which was just noise in the beginning
much like with cans diffusion models are
ridiculously faithful to the image how
faithfully exactly we can see with glide
which is open ai's next iteration on
diffusion models before glide open ai's
work on diffusion models generated
images from class labels but now this
next iteration has successfully
integrated textual information into the
generation process
so we can now produce images from text
with diffusion models
but it's funny how the authors had to
smash in the text information into
glides to convince it to pay attention
to it so let's break it down here
glide does the following thing we have
our data consisting of images in their
captions after the forward diffusion
process we have noisier and noisier
versions of the images
the diffusion model is trained to
reverse this process using a unit based
architecture very much like the previous
paper from openai the belligerent one
beating gans but now the backward
diffusion is taking the text prompt into
account too so the glide authors took
the text encoded it through a
transformer what a surprise it's
transformer and took the final token
embedding as a class conditioning in the
diffusion model so now the neural
network needs to generate an image with
less and less noise but has more
guidance from this additional input of a
class specific variables specifying what
kind of image to generate or rather text
specific variable but the authors did
not resort to this because seemingly
though the paper is not explicit about
this the text information as such was
not enough
so additionally each
each attention layer in the model is
attending to all the text tokens that
the transformer produces when encoding
the text
cool that should be enough to make the
textual information evident for glide
right
no
i mean at least for the training
procedure it does suffice but it is
still not enough so the authors hack the
text even more into the diffusion model
that is too faithful to the image
modality and they do it at inference
time so brace yourself this is not
training anymore the authors tried out
clip guided diffusion to make the text
more persuasive when it comes to image
generation from text the idea here is to
use an extra model to make the generated
image better correspond to text the
extra model here is clip because clip
also from open ai is trained to predict
a similarity score between image and
text so to generate an image with clip
guided diffusion the authors first let
glide denoise the image conditioned on
text but then they further guide the
process by adding the
gradient of the image sentence
similarity of clip with respect to the
image
this coffee bean slowed down like
conceptually this takes the initial
denoised image and moves it into the
direction in which clip predicts a high
image text match
this is like deep dream if you're
familiar with that but now we dream into
the direction of what clip thinks is a
better image text match this is a trick
to make the generations match the text
better because as we previously said it
seems like glide kind of wants to ignore
the text if led on its own classifier
guided diffusion is one way to make the
text information more obvious to glide
during inference but there is also
another way the classifier-free guidance
the authors used and it worked better in
their case as the name already says no
extra model is needed here it's just a
weird trick applied at each diffusion
step to emphasize the text even more
first glide produces the image twice
once with text and once without access
to the text then we compute the
difference between the diffusion step
with text and without text and with this
difference we now know in which
direction to move if we want to go from
no text to text so if we take the text
less generation and add this difference
scared by quite a lot the output of the
model without text information is
heavily extrapolated into the direction
of text information is this a weird hack
yes it is but it works the results of
glide are too convincing just look at
this glide is trained on the same data
as dali has almost four times fewer
parameters than dali but nails the
photorealism aspect the authors
conducted human evaluation experiments
where it is clear that the majority
preferred glides generation over the
blurrier and messier outputs of dali but
it's not all great news for glide and
diffusion models in general diffusion
models having to go through all the
diffusion steps sequentially 150 in
glide's case
take much longer than gans for example
further bad news is that openai being
open ai didn't release the full glide
model but a smaller glide version
trained on a smaller curated data set
and how should i tell you these news it
it cannot produce the avocado armchair i
i tried a few times with different noise
to get different generations but nah
no real avocado armchair miss
coffee bean is sad now
is there anything cool you can produce
with the released model find the link in
the description if you're interested and
let us know in the comments what you
think about openai not releasing the big
version of the model thanks for watching
we're so happy that we finally released
this glide video it has been waiting in
the coffee machine for quite a while now
but
miss coffee bean had other
coffees to go first
can't wait to see you next time